[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à vérifier des compteurs alors
effectivement je travaille chez edf
frères sont de maromme on dirait un gars
qui vient chez what pourront faire des
travaux ça va mon cd contente de
retrouver tous les mercredis je connais
un petit peu l'équipe bien sûr
alors il a dû ralentir à 0 par vincent
d'honoraires par coeur parce qu'on était
morts tous les deux donc c'est énorme
mais si vous savez que la saison 10 de
danse avec les stars s'est terminé ce
week-end est évidemment et oui je vous
assure je raye j'allais même pas
référencés et à tf1 forcément vous savez
qui il se demande s'il faut continuer ou
pas bien sûr vous savez ça et comme je
pense à tous ces hommes qui veulent que
ça continue pour qu'il puisse sortir
avec leurs potes le samedi soir pendant
que la meuf elle regarde des gens qu'on
connaît pas danser un foxtrot
j'ai voulu les aider comment sauver
danse avec les stars c'est une nouvelle
enquête de baba j'aime bien faire
[Musique]
powell c'est l'équivalent féminin de
l'animal plus connu sous le nom de fauve
hautot chaque année au mois de septembre
tf1 présente à la danseuse la star qui
va l'accompagner
quand on le dit que son partenaire
serait sami el gueddari votto a
logiquement répondu je sais pas c'est
qui danse avec les stars se trouve
actuellement sur le fil
du rasoir
danse avec les stars s'est inspiré d'une
célèbre émission de flavie flament qu'un
les stars ne sont pas sur le parquet
mais à leur domicile pour relancer les
audiences le public veut voir des stars
des personnes charismatiques qui font
rêver les jeunes et les seniors
il faut donc engager une star
internationale
un homme capable de booster n'importe
quelle émission et qui en a dans le
pantalon
cet homme c'est bien sûr fabien que
en effet il al'avantage d'être un
habitué des costumes de scène
et surtout ils dansent régulièrement en
gala avec fauve autour alors comment
sauver danse avec les stars
est ce que va bien que présentera un
jour danse avec les stars décédées
est-ce que l'année prochaine nous aurons
la chance de voir enfin au casting
jean-daniel choukroun qui a failli jouer
un figurant dans plus belle la vie et
surtout quand est ce que tf1 intégrera
dans son jury
le chorégraphe mourad m benyamna plus
connu sous le nom de bouder autant de
questions auxquelles l'inspecteur baba
ne va pas répondre du terme à tout ça on
va savoir qui est le 21e tarbes alors il
ya un gros suspense cette semaine alors
quand une star meurt et que fabien
lecoeuvre vient raconter une anecdote en
plateau sur cette fameuse star la star
peut pas le contredire puisque elle est
morte mais bien sûr le problème que
rencontre fabien lecoeuvre c'est qu'ici
on reçoit des artistes vivants
donc quand il donne des infos sur eux
ils peuvent le dire directement que
c'est des conneries s'arrête jamais sauf
la main ça peut arriver là et souvent
même s'est décrédibilisé pas à fabriquer
il a toujours manqué bonnes infos et il
est très fort et bien voilà je le dis il
est très fort mais vous y trompez pas
moi-même à tout le monde attention parce
que famille raconte tellement bien les
histoires qu'on pourra y croire sauf que
c'est jamais vraiment l'histoire c'est
toujours presque l'histoire presse que
les bonnes dates alors voici une
nouvelle émission présentée par fabien
lecoeuvre secret presque d'histoire
le jour qui a changé la vie finalement
d'evelyne thomas c'est ce fameux 22
novembre n'ont pas 74 1989 c'était la
première émission de c'est mon choix
89 oui pour 22 19 22 novembre 89 et 90
très belle intervention que ça bien
d'accord
[Musique]
excuse-moi rochelle
elle avait dirais que c'est changer et
si les eaux sociaux qu'est ce qui se
passe c'est vrai et non pas j'ai été
repéré grâce à cette chanson réseaux les
réseaux sociaux comme ça qu exacerber la
nationale avec suis malade je mettrais
et quand on va chez renault il ya
toujours ce disque dédicacé par brassens
est un peu son porte bonheur dans son
bureau de fo et cgc
et c'est une des plus belles histoires
j'en perds c'est vrai cette histoire d
un conan franchement je la connaissais
pas
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
avec l'argent qu'ils vont prendre après
ces 10 euros par livre un parti dont on
parle est bien sûr non elle dit
c'est 10 euros c'est le prix symbolique
du chèque est remis sur à l'auteur
symboliquement au nom du prix mais après
avec son éditeur le contrat qu'il a
c'est en moyenne de 10
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il est très très fort voilà je redis que
merci fabien parce que il a beaucoup
d'autodérision et si vous avez cru très
heureux qu'il ait dit l'euro je me
permets j'insiste de tout ce sont tous
des ignorants parce qu'il ya des prix
c'est sympa mais ça jamais non mais je
parlais les scripts et autour de moi à
ce moment sur ses terres il ya des
primes dont on ne parle jamais parce
qu'il ya des contrats des doubles
contrats ou des cours sur parallèle tout
ce qui est merchandising tout ce qui
rapporte les signatures dans les salons
du livre et que cela et les primes par
5000 10000 15000 et 20000 personne n'en
parle sur les contrôles chez mes bateaux
dont on parle c'est à dire quand on a un
gros noms n'ont pas entendu les
commerçants un nouveau chouchou se mange
froid
ouais ses remarques et oui alors parmi
vos chroniques l'astre joie pyramide oui
c'est facile rend à cultiver cultiver
c'est matthieu delormeau laisser
quelqu'un ou un autre l'équipe l'a
maintenant trois mois il est
extraordinaire et s'ils s'habituent
vitaux à maurras radar cas il reste
quand même très paris-première prix
goncourt exposition au grand palais donc
forcément vovan et vos goûts musicaux
bon il n'y vas kiffer mais je pense dans
dix quinze ans pas avant
alors je sais vous aviez mes premiers
épisodes voici le retour de la tête
anona j'adore
vous entendez balavoine balavoine
m'avait raconté qu'il a fait une prise
en studio pour enregistrer way et avec
johnny lui il ya 30 ans soit une cote
françois n'a jamais fait une prisé prix
[Musique]
j'ai déjeuné avec un ami dans un
restaurant italien chez pinault non pire
ses pizzas et hop
[Musique]
non mais oh c'est pas du tout mon truc
vous allez voir c'est comme l'eau avec
un dj nico
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ils sont avec nous ils souffrent vous
savez ce que j'aime chez jean michel
maire c'est qu'il fait des vannes
surtout quand il se rend compte que ça
va ne passe pas c'est un mélange de
détresse et dormi de rentrer chez lui il
fait des coups de pression aussi d un
petit peu là vous allez voir ce qui est
magnifique c'est votre relation est ce
votre tête jean-michel voici un nouvel
épisode du petit jean-michel quand le
petit jean michel à une vanne que tout
le monde fait semblant de ne pas
entendre il la répète
jusqu'au drame ça fait quoi comme et
tutoie déjà j'ai fait des études
classiques normal
le petit jean michel a une spécialité
dans l'humour le jeu de mots c'est
l'émission nrj
céline chauveton antonia jackson moi je
te jure élections directes montcuq
quentin crise difficile de sauter du
haut de la tour tf1 amortie par des
airbags
ça inspire jean-michel le sniper chaque
lot avec je dis oui on va l'organiser
pour un prime franchement après ça on va
retirer le que je vais rebuy en dessous
[Musique]
est ce que le petit jean michel ne sais
pas c'est qu'il ne faut surtout pas
tenter de vannes sur le fils du patron
saint jacques bino est en vacances
scolaires et que forcément là il avec
des meufs tout ça alors tati la bouée
narcé buenos aires est sur l'autoroute
on pensait pas ils s'amusent
[Musique]
amy est magnifiquement franchement
stéphane jean michel tout le monde le
sait il pourrait que tu repères les
coups de pression qui me fait aussi avec
plaisir à regarder rire et fait peur bon
attention vous avez pas bien parce que
je sais depuis une semaine la france
retient son souffle
existe il est temps de désigner le
tarbes à bâle la musique de suspense est
pas le tabac jo rappelle vincent pour si
vous connaissez pas que c'est celui ou
celle que le plus tacler ses collègues
pendant cette semaine et ça fait une
forte le suspense est insoutenable que
vous gagnez cyril ça fait parfois que
exactement et on al'impression fait que
s'il vous gagnerez tout le temps non ça
vous ne pouvez pas gagner tout le temps
je pense qu'elle soit vous êtes un peu
moins en forme touareg est ce qu'il
pensait que cette semaine vous allez
garder un niveau de tarbes habitude
assez élevé vous pensez toujours way 21e
tarbes à bas prix frappe de l'histoire
de touche pas à mon poste
alors
les jouets et franchement cette semaine
c'était encore plus forte à l'est des
champions va céder coupe du monde
en pleine forme regardez moi qui sont
réussite aux terroristes au bénin tu
devrais pas moins de trois ans pour être
sûr que c'est le bon choix corrects pour
crochet etc à personne mais bien sûr je
partage un peu la même logique qui vous
apportez vous attend des commandes
cheikh secondes seulement degré libre
avec intelligence
j'espère qu'ils vont vous livrer bientôt
combien avez vous de sur instagram de
followers 750
ouais c'est formidable cet animateur
humoriste aussi donc assez compliqué
parce que je sais quand son avocat
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
si vous êtes malade vous restez chez
vous la connaissez le parfum de mamie
mais non mais c'est vrai il ya marine où
il est il est fort pas du tout et c'est
rien c'est passé la naphtaline
et vous
le but c'est faux vous puissiez vous
êtes magnétique alors bravo ce rictus
oui